- We're here today to get face tattoos.
(music)
- Not like face face
tattoos, but like portraits
of each other's faces on the other's body.
We've been together, what like --
- About five years.
Married for four and a half of them.
- Why not just commit
to a lifetime of like
our youngest and best selves
on each other's bodies forever?
- It's unusual, certainly,
but I think it's kind of
a cool extension of our existing
commitment to each other
and if for whatever reason that changed
down the road, lasers exist.
- Hey!
♫ You had me at hello
♫ Girl, I almost fainted
♫ Too much for my young heart and soul
- Hey, I'm Zoey and
we're here at The Warren.
This is my shop and I have been tattooing
for about 17 years now.
I'm a pretty versatile artist.
My strength would be portraits or realism.
There is just something about faces that
when you can capture somebody's face
and their expression that
is kind of a special thing.
So, it's just something I
have always been drawn to.
People worry about, "Oh,
what if they break up?"
But I think tattoos
are very much bookmarks
of moments in your life
and regardless of what
happens to them, this is
a big part of their life.
So, I think it's cool.
(uptempo music)
Where are you guys thinking
about putting these?
- I was kind of leaning more
towards my shoulder area.
Somewhere in this real estate here.
- On your chest?
- Yeah, kind of...
- Cool.
- I'm a little on the fence but I'm open
to like, placing it in different areas.
- And we can stencil
you in a couple places
and see what feels right.
- [Kelly] If that's okay.
- [Zoey] Yeah.
- Taylor, you want to go first?
- Yeah! Let's do it!
- Can you get naked?
- Yeah!
(music)
- [Kelly] I don't know, do
you feel weird about that?
- That's true.
I almost feel like I'm an evil twin growth
or something that's growing out of you.
- [Zoey] You guys want to move it?
- Yeah, let's move it.
(uptempo music)
- I like that so much better.
- Awesome, I love it.
- It's perfect.
♫ Let's make it last forever
♫ 'Cause the night's still young
♫ It's true I feel the pressure
♫ Every time you're gone
♫ As long as we're together
♫ This moment lasts forever
("Wait" by NoMBe)
- So weird.
It's eerie because it
looks like me so much
but it's also just sort of weird
to see my face on your body.
And know that it's never
going anywhere. (laughs)
("Wait" by NoMBe)
- I think the sound of the machine
is actually very soothing
so it just becomes
like a meditative state, eventually.
(uptempo music)
- We're all done!
Time for you guys to get to take a look.
- Oh my God.
I'm not ready yet, you go first. (laughs)
- Okay. Alright!
Moment of truth.
- It's happening!
- Whoa!
- Oh my God!
- That's awesome!
- It's like frightening how much prettier
I am as a tattoo.
- [Taylor] Oh hush. You
do look great, though.
- I mean, yeah. Holy crap that like...
- This is so awesome!
- That looks just like my face.
- Shocker.
- (laughs) I know, can you believe it?
- It works. Are you ready?
- Are you excited?
- Yeah, I am.
- Oh my God!
- [Taylor] What?
- It's you!
- [Taylor] That is me.
- Look how excited you are
to live on my arm forever.
- During it, I was like, oh God,
what if I hate this?
But it actually makes me excited
to see you excited on my arm.
You look so happy to be here!
- That's me!
- (Kelly laughs)
- [Taylor] Thanks Zoey!
That's amazing work!
- [Kelly] I mean, it's like you've
made us even better looking.
- You guys take good pictures, so.
- I also feel like I'm going to be
less inclined to get mad at you sometimes
just because you look so happy here.
- [Taylor] Tattoo's already paying off.
(Kelly laughs)
- Do you think other
people should do this?
- Yes! Absolutely.
I mean look how well this turned out.
Hey do you want to make out?
- I mean, like?
- Yeah!
- Nope, that stings too much
I'm not ready for that
sort of weirdness just yet.
- Coming up soon.
♫ You had me at hello
♫ Girl, I almost fainted
♫ Too much for my young heart and soul
♫ To bear to feel